[Music]
hi
from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
we're glad you're with us american
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple a
eight two five
five
two two five
george i haven't seen such an uproar and
i don't know when
dave i made the mistake of asking on
instagram what are y'all's thoughts on
this whole student loan thing and
apparently we're not the only ones with
opinions
you think i've never seen people so
angry
yeah it's um it's a deal it's a real
deal so if you haven't heard president
biden announced yesterday that uh he is
for giving ten thousand dollars uh for
of student loan debt for anyone making
under 125 000 if you were getting a pell
grant at the time twenty thousand
dollars
um
no idea how he's going to fund it
no idea how it's going to be implemented
no i i mean the government officials are
running around like like uh ants on a
hot tin shovel i mean it's it's just
like
because they don't know what how the
crap they're gonna do this because it's
kind of like you remember when they
announced the ppp thing oh yeah and we
didn't have the staff to execute the
stuff
and people started spending the money
before they could actually get it and
then they never got it so here's the
thing
we still don't know
i don't know maybe it's out there and
i've missed it but i i said yesterday on
the show i think he has to get
congressional approval on this i don't
think you can do a 300 billion dollar
transaction without congressional
approval i don't think you can do that
with an executive order i might be wrong
i'm not a legal scholar but pretty sure
i'm right which means he's got to run
this through congress and here's what's
interesting
you won't know if this is real
by the time you vote in the midterms
brilliant political play just leave the
carrot dangling well it may not go
through
good chance it doesn't go through
exactly as it is i mean you try to get
something through congress come on even
if they're on your side right
and if it doesn't go through by midterms
and congress flips over
and it's no longer democratically run it
will never go through and so biden just
got all you people stirred up if that's
the case for nothing
if that's how it goes down
now won't that be a politically genius
move well
both bases even more yeah create more
political divisiveness i told you guys
four months ago three months ago that
when you know when they moved it to
december to august 31st on the extension
of the no student loan interest i told
you
midterms are coming this president will
announce something in the last week of
august about student loan forgiveness
and it probably will have no teeth now i
was wrong about second part because this
has got teeth he stated exactly what
he's going to do and it is substantial i
thought it was going to be some wispy
thing like he said the other day we
forgave nine billion dollars worth and
it wasn't he didn't do anything it was a
school that went broke and they have to
forgive it it had nothing to do with one
of his programs it was regulations that
were already in place but he's walking
strutting around taking political credit
for it so uh very interesting though so
he did he you know but you know he's the
worst economic presidency since jimmy
carter i mean the guy everything he
touched turns to poop when it comes to
the economy i mean we got we got
inflation we got high gas pumps we got a
recession we got stock market going down
we got interest rates going up we got a
housing market slowing i don't know when
the economy smelled this bad it's been a
long time and i'm old well the timing is
as the young kids say sus which means
suspicious dave i'm teaching you
something here yeah that's what they say
yeah it is us for sure it's a why wait a
year that's not really it's brilliant
political move yes so what you do you
back up for your midterms where the
democrats are going to take a bloodbath
and you throw a hail mary
and you go i'm going to help you i'm
going to give you more money
only you're not going to really know if
i am by the time you have to vote
oh it's just do you think that
positioning is from if you're a
political manipulator the positioning is
just brilliant
it's just brilliant it has nothing to do
with being good or righteous or
principled no i'm just saying if if i
was running for president i would do the
exact same thing i mean that's just if i
had no principles i mean that's exactly
what i would do
because it's just the way he set it up
and it all and you know now he does
apparently have the executive order
ability to extend through the end of the
year no interest so that's good we can
kick those of you that guy if you do get
the ten thousand dollar forgiveness we
are unabashedly happy for you no no
sarcasm whatsoever we want to celebrate
anyone who's anybody who gets help from
anything that is burdening them we love
it we're happy for you it's all good
where if someone is broke and out of
work and can't feed their kids and they
get welfare checks we're not mad at them
we want to help you do better than that
over time because that's not a recipe
for a good life but for the short term
we're not going to shame you for taking
help from the government that is legally
offered
ever yeah never have uh now we'll tell
you if we think it's stupid and we'll
tell you if it's not sustainable if it's
a bad long-term plan for your life which
usually government help falls in all of
those things but uh but but
so we're happy for you
but we're also angry simultaneously with
all of you who paid off your loans and
did the right thing and were moral and
said i signed this i have an obligation
i'm going to honor my obligation i'm a
person of integrity and now i got
screwed or i feel like i got screwed and
the reason you feel like you got screwed
because you got screwed that's why you
feel simple
so some people have a right to be angry
people have a right to be happy it's
it's a mixed bag here but most people
are angry because they know how well
that's in our that's in our feed
yeah i mean where our feed is going to
be people like that it's not you know if
you went over in some left-wing thing
some left-wing whatever wingnut thing
you'd have their feed is all that he's
saint biden or whatever that's that
because that's just you know we got a
bit of an echo chamber going here sure
but there is precedent that i'm worried
about where people go okay well why pay
off any more student loans well what if
there's more forgiveness and here's the
thing i've been saying this since the
beginning and it's in the documentary
borrowed futures i've said it years and
years and years ago it's been saying
over and over you really can't forgive
student loans while you're still making
them if the reason you're forgiving them
is they're horrible and damaging to
people and yet you continue to make them
that's intellectually dishonest
so if anybody else with common sense
other than a politician would go wait
this is hurting people first let's stop
it
and then let's try to help the people
that were hurt stop the bleeding and i
could i could get involved in that
conversation yeah but that has nothing
to do with politics that's just like the
right thing to do in common sense and
stuff if this wasn't politics that would
still be the solution it's not to put a
band-aid on it so you know what are you
gonna do with bubba who takes out ten
thousand dollars in
january we're going to be right back
where we started even if we forgave
every student loan across america what
do we back break to where we started
today yeah four years from now because
they're still making them
so i mean
you know when you're 18 you can't buy
beer but you can go 100 000 in debt
there's just something stupid about that
y'all
but it's our american right dave
i mean
um
i don't even know how to respond to that
that's so stupid i just wanted to throw
that out there for you
it's our american right to be stupid
that's right well you do have the right
to be stupid that is the beauty of
freedom is that you you got the right to
be dumb
um to the tune of uh 300 billion dollars
pastor used to say the beauty of america
is you have the right to be wrong and so
uh that but i agree with that
it's just an interesting discussion it's
interesting when you view it for the
political lens which we're not politics
people but this one's kind of sus
well i think on it quick thank you gen z
they just you just gonna see just here
listeners youtube listeners just are all
running around in circles cheering and
throwing up confetti right now i'm just
happy i thought dave something new it's
hard to teach an old dog new tricks be
careful
somebody called me a dog a young dog new
tricks
you still call me a dog dang it i can't
win with you people
ah
hey maybe you people aren't having fun
but we are this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
open phones this hour this is the ramsey
show
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host so george here's a little math
for you 300 billion
a billion is a thousand million
a thousand million
hundred billion is three hundred
thousand
million
if you wanna zero you could give three
hundred thousand people a million
dollars
and they'd be millionaires
wow
that's wild
that's wild that's about it's the same
exact math that just blows my mind
patrick is with us patrick's in columbus
ohio hi patrick how are you
hey dave thank you for having me
sure what's up
hey so
i paid off my student loans back in 2020
um i didn't
from about from about march 13th to
when i finally paid them off
there's about six grand in there and i'm
reading that i could potentially ask a
refund
um on that paint on those payments
and my thought hood is that this news
coming out whether it happens
um i won't do it
it sounds shady but uh
is it a possibility that i could get
some money since
i paid off my student loans but uh get
the government to pay a portion of it
for me so here's the thing
the biden administration has given
almost zero details
on how this is going to be implemented
or the nuances things like you're
talking about
and everybody in his brother has written
an opinion piece including me um now on
this whole thing and uh and so you know
what we're doing is we're guessing how
it's all gonna roll out so that has not
been announced by the white house
that was announced by someone in an
opinion piece that they think it might
happen that way
yeah and the details are not out on this
so um i i you know but i don't know
anything because i never thought we'd
actually get to the place that we
forgave student loans
okay so i'm stupid i just my ability to
i was able to predict that he was going
to do something by the end of the year
into the by the end of the august by
correctly but i was not able to predict
that he actually is going to do
something of substance which maybe he
hadn't yet we'll see but so i don't know
if this is real i think that you know
we there's no indication from an
official that this is real but what
you're proposing i have seen what you're
talking about though um so let's see
what would i do if i were in your shoes
would i go back and get the money for
free
um
here's here
let me answer it this way i try to
answer questions what would i do you
know and that's to be fair in other
words not to be hypocritical so
here's the thing
i have been against the lottery in the
state of tennessee since it started many
many many years ago
because it is a tax on poor people
the vast majority of the people the zip
codes that raise 80 of the lottery money
are poor zip codes
the vast majority of the money going in
the lottery more than 80 of it is from
poor people
and so lower income zip codes now
what's the lottery used for in the state
of tennessee it's used to give each kid
three to four thousand dollars towards
their tuition to go to college so it's
poor people sending middle class and
upper class people's kids to college
um and so i'm morally against that and i
campaigned against it when the state
passed it i obviously my side lost we've
had it for a long time but when my kids
went to college there was free lottery
money available for my kids to go to
college i could have as a
multi-multi-multi-millionaire accepted
at the time it was three thousand i
think it's more than that now three or
four thousand dollars per kid per year
towards their tuition it was available
to me it was legal
it was the program
but i had campaigned against it on the
auspices that it was morally wrong
because i don't believe more poor people
sending rich people's kids to college is
right
and taking advantage of intact it's a
tax on the poor that's what the lottery
is
and so i don't believe it's right so i
just i don't do it
now so so what i when my kids got ready
to college i did not take that money
because to me
that would be a lack of integrity after
i had campaigned against it so
if i if i were in the situation today as
hard at hardcore as i've been against
student loan forgiveness for me my
family to actually accept
student loan forgiveness would be super
hypocritical agreed
agreed so if so i'll leave that on you
and it's not saying you're right or
wrong either way but if you have had
like strong conversations with your
friends over coffee and you say this is
wrong this is wrong this is wrong i
don't think it's morally right then you
should not accept it if you're
ambivalent you're kind of in the middle
i think you're okay morally to accept it
what do you think there's nothing
unethical here if i'm in issues i'm
going hey i could do
money yeah the only thing to be
unethical is if you took a stand against
it and then took it sure
but to say hey i'm going to get this
refund i'm going to apply it to my baby
steps it's going to help me in a
financial journey and this is a legal
there's no loopholes here i think he
should go ahead and do it and this is
coming from studentaid.gov education
department this is where this news is
coming from so it's it's a legitimate
source but nothing's actually happened
yet so it's still a little bit of
we don't really know what could happen
here's the thing they did not write this
that i mean they did not write this
proposal from biden
biden sent it to them they're saying
that's not related they have not had
time yet they're guessing what it might
look like too
and so no it's i it's not coming out of
the white house it's coming out of the
deep bowels of a bureaucracy and we'll
see if any of that actually makes it to
the light of day i you know if you're
ambivalent kind of in the middle
agnostic to the whole thing you don't
have a stand on it take the money
if you're all for student loan
forgiveness i would take the money you
should be able to do that without
conscience but if you've been raising a
banner like i have for many years this
is wrong then um
or at least it's wrong while you're
still making the loans
you know and then after that we can
discuss everything it's just infuriating
but then you have to do this so i didn't
take the lottery money i didn't take the
ppp money
our company could have gotten a big
check during ppp and i'm telling people
this is a bad idea stay away from this
it's going to turn into a loan you're
stepping up on a trapdoor these guys are
going to choke you later you need to
stay out of it and that ppp thing very
quietly has ruined some lives
and i'm so glad we didn't take it but
for me to stay out be on the radio going
it's horrible and then y'all send me my
check you know
i'll take one yeah so it's basically if
it's not against your values go for it
nothing unethical about it yeah so
that's the thing so for here's another
example the titans stadium came into
nashville many years ago and like almost
every stadium or sports complex that
comes in they asked the city for
free taxes no taxes for years or forever
they asked the city to put to borrow
money and put into the project some
cases ask the city to build the project
or half of it or whatever
and uh that's government money
citizens money going into a private
enterprise and it's not like nfl owners
need money hello okay but but i actually
was okay with them doing that which
sounds weird to a guy like me but and
the reason is is because of what that
creates in the overall economy
it's not necessarily the titans
themselves or the sports team itself
that's the big deal it's all the things
that it does for the economy
all the other jobs and all the other
things that happen in the economy
that is around it it may it's a good
deal for the city the city makes more
and increased tax revenue off of the
other things than it then they gave up
in the revenue on the deal so i said do
it okay and so when we did this piece of
ground that and we built this building
we were given some tax breaks because
we're a huge employer in the state of
tennessee i accepted those
and so uh you know that is not
incongruent that is not incongruent um
because i say dave that's not fair you
take tax credits what's the difference
here yeah what do you say to those well
the difference is number one uh i didn't
borrow something and then ask for it to
be forgiven after i promised to repay it
there's no there's no value issue on the
line number one but number two what i'm
saying is i've been consistent on what
i've done in private and the stands of
taking public
and that's all we would ask any of you
to do
is is you know whatever you whatever you
believe just be that all the time and
quit being freaking well you you know i
don't know what the gen z version of
two-faced is but we used to call it
two-faced quit being two-faced you're
different on sunday than you are on
monday
stop it
you know why don't you just be like the
same all the time
and so consequently you know my
christian friends are as angry at me for
being not christian enough as my
non-christian friends are because i'm a
christian and good god you just can't
win you've never been in the business of
making everyone happy dave we know that
really
that's one thing i do know about you and
we love it well well we you know welcome
to the parade
uh horse gate right welcome to the
parade this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage daniel and melissa are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you better than we deserve welcome
where do you live
uh so we are from mount arlington new
jersey it's about 35 minutes
west of new york city oh okay perfect
good to have you guys welcome to
nashville how much debt did you pay off
uh so we paid off 97
776 dollars why to go how long did this
take 22 months good for you and your
range of income during that time uh
between 60 and 170. wow nice jump okay
so uh what do you guys do for a living
so i'm in sales
i'm a teacher okay was somebody not
working and then somebody started
working or what happened to that income
no we uh got married oh yeah okay okay
so who started who was the 60
uh so that was me that was you okay and
then your income went up and you got
married both correct okay cool so you
all been married by two years
yeah just a little bit just underneath
yeah good very cool and 22 months later
boom it's done what kind of debt was the
98 000
so it was pretty much all my debt it was
68
uh private student loans 25 federal
student loans and then 4k in car okay
it's all gone all gone wow how old are
you two so i'm 29 i'm 30. okay yeah so
uh melissa let me get this straight yeah
um
you like this guy so much
that you're gonna marry into a hundred
thousand dollars worth of stupid oh yeah
i married into that i married into the
ramsey show
yeah we listen uh this all goes together
it all goes together
oh my gosh you can't escape this exactly
we're listening to the podcast on our
way to our honeymoon yeah oh my goodness
now that that you're just a real
romantic yeah
you're that guy i can tell oh my gosh
you got the ramsay show on your
honeymoon there's something wrong man
good gosh this is part of our
pre-marital counseling there you go so
melissa were you on board day one with
the ramsay stuff you're like all right i
mean you clearly have been doing so well
financially to not complain with any
debt yeah so my my dad's really into
finances so i was i was lucky enough to
graduate college without any debt uh
moved home i got a condo and kind of
just followed his neil guckin program so
then uh when he was talking about
learning about a budget and moving into
that i was all for it so yeah i'm
usually i'm usually one who's kind of
strict on a budget anyway so that was
nice
hey this guy's got common sense maybe he
is attractive
yeah
good for you good choice yeah well done
see that marrying into debt is not a
problem marrying into debt that i'm not
gonna do anything about it that's a
problem so you didn't have that issue so
well done y'all very cool so first order
of business in the marriages we got to
clean up this mess we're done boom boom
boom boom boom
what's the secret to paying off 98 000
in 22 months um so i mean it started
when i wanted to get married i didn't
want to bring the debt into the marriage
and it was about taking accountability
so i said i signed up for this debt i
need to get rid of this debt this is my
debt there were years where i didn't
even look at my student loan bill i
thought i'd be paying it off forever i
actually did the math over the past
seven years of paying it i paid 148 000
including all of the interest good god
um so i was doing a lot of dave ish
uh and then
i met her and that's when it kind of all
changed for me i said i got to be the
man that she needs me to be let's get
start getting this deck cleaned up and
let's uh let's move forward so we cash
flowed
uh
engagement ring our wedding
and then we had a our first child
shortly after we got married she's three
months old she's three months old
yeah so that's reagan very cool yeah
ramsay was a runner up for the second
time
we want to creep you guys out so middle
name show that would be extra weird
wow you guys are incredible yeah so what
do you tell a couple who maybe isn't on
the same page who didn't come from this
background and they're trying to figure
this out they want to pay off the debt
but they can't quite get on the plan we
just say it's worth it because when our
i mean she was our surprise little baby
after honeymoon and all that kind of
stuff but to kind of go into that new
adventure in life it's already a lot of
stress built up um to go in that without
having any debt behind us i feel like
it's taken the stress off and allowed us
to
still live our lives enjoy that new
chapter even with all the new parent
stress and i grew up in a household full
of debt and i knew
the stress that that put on me
and i didn't want to bring her
into that stress either
and
you know a lot of getting rid of my
student loan debt too was
me
showing my mother that you know she
raised me the right way even though we
made a mistake by getting the student
loans in the first place i didn't want
her to think
that
it was holding me back from my life i
didn't want her to carry that burden i
didn't want to carry that burden anymore
uh so we
you know i changed
changed my family tree wow it was worth
it you know there's a uh
statistic that uh tom stanley who wrote
millionaire next door also wrote a book
called the millionaire mind and he
studied people that 10 million or more
and he's found 38 characteristics of
those people demographic characteristics
character characteristics all kinds of
things about those people but the thing
that showed up the most often the most
common characteristic the number one
correlating
statistic in those people was
integrity and honor
and that's what you've brought up like
four times in this conversation already
integrity and honor integrity and honor
integrity and honor there's a a huge tie
between people of integrity and honor
and their ability to build wealth it
just it goes together and you know we
hear these lies out there that only
crooks get wealthy and all that it's
actually exactly the opposite in the
actual data
the data shows up and you guys are
walking testimony that very cool yeah i
want to show my mom that i was good even
though we messed up i can stand up i
want to be the right kind of man for my
wife i grew up in a household with a
stress i don't want that on my daughter
all of these things are service
integrity honor statements coming from
daniel powerful stuff daniel powerful
man you're a good guy you guys are a
great couple this is amazing i'm so
proud of y'all thank you very cool i bet
your parents are both proud oh yeah yes
yeah very cool my mother was the one who
introduced me to you ah okay i said okay
we made a mess but here's how you clean
it up yeah exactly
good stuff way to go you guys thank you
so proud of you we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure a
copy of total money makeover for you to
give away to someone because you live
like no one else so later you can live
and give
like no one else and a one year
subscription to financial peace
university if you've not gone through it
yet go through it it's got the uh new
videos in it it's the best we've ever
done including george and dr john
deloney and rachel cruz in there as well
and uh and me and so be sure you go
through that and couldn't go way to go
guys way to go thank you for coming all
the way to nashville to celebrate with
us it's an honor to see your smiling
faces
we'll be back pleasure to be here very
well done very well done all right
daniel and melissa from jersey 98 000
paid off in 22 months right after they
got married 60 to 170 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream are you
ready yep three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
man oh man oh man that's how it's done a
lot of transformation right there
way beyond just becoming debt free i owe
this money i need to pay this money this
is an obligation i took on i'm gonna and
when a young guy like that says those
kinds of phrases uh it's an indication
that his future is really bright
because uh you know the the thing that
is rare
is is not
uh people with an opinion the thing that
is rare is people with character
with deep kinds of honor
and integrity and uh a sense of
uh
of service for their family
uh and that's selflessness rather than
selfishness those kinds of people don't
take many selfies
definitely not that's not how they work
it's not all about me it's not about me
it's not about me i'm not trying to
highlight me you know and those are the
kinds of people that
all the data that we have indicates that
that's a long play that's playing long
ball
and that's going to take you to a really
cool place i was talking to rachel this
morning about folks that are upset they
paid off their debt and now there's this
forgiveness that could be looming and
they were messaging me saying it changed
my character to pay off that debt it
showed me that i can take control of my
life i can take charge that life doesn't
have to happen to me and i know it
sounds trite but that's priceless way
beyond ten thousand dollars of
forgiveness what that does to the
trajectory of your life and the success
that you'll experience
man that's powerful stuff so if that's
you out there we see you and i'm proud
of you for the sacrifice you've made for
the person that you've became the person
you're becoming following this journey
wow
that may be the first time on the ramsay
show someone feels seen
i hope you feel seen this is for gen z
dave that's what it's all about you and
your language this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personalities my
co-host today when the team gets
together at ramsey we talk a lot about
our mission
to change america's toxic culture
it makes us mad to see people get messed
over in this culture by stuff like debt
or watch kids sign away their future
with a student loan
or watch folks
you know take jobs that they hate
that kind of stuff we don't want that to
happen so the people that work here
we're on a crusade it's not a j.o.b it's
a mission
now that sounds cheesy to you then you
don't want to work here if that sounds
like a passion you share you need to
check out all the roles at ramsey
solutions that we're looking to fill
we'll probably hire about 300 people
this year there's never been a better
time to find a job doing work you love
we need developers ux designers
content writers we need people to help
us build digital products that actually
change people's lives
so when you're writing code here it
actually matters
to see what it's like to wear do work
that matters with us before you apply
you can follow us on facebook or
instagram by searching ramsey careers or
you can apply for your dream job at
ramseysolutions.com
careers ramsey solutions dot com
slash
careers
i tell the guys that we were onboarding
a group we did onboarding about every
two weeks and i was
meeting with the newbies coming on board
the new guys uh monday for a little bit
i told them i said this is gonna be the
best job you've ever had the absolute
hardest work you'll ever do in your life
because people around here work so hard
they're so smart and they care so deeply
that if you don't you won't fit in the
bar is high it is it is it's a great
place to work but it is now we do go
home at 5 30. i mean we're not parking
lots empty we'll yell at you if you're
here longer than that yeah we don't want
you here once you go home be with your
family but uh we don't work 80 hours a
week but when we're at work we work we
got stuff to do i haven't stopped all
morning i get i get it
and i set the pace and everybody's got
to keep up with that then so and i have
for 30 years so and we play hard too
work hard play hard as one of our events
eat a lot dave during lunch the money i
spend on food around here insane just
amazing you people eat biscuits like
it's amazing all right dayton is with us
dayton's in wichita kansas hi dayton how
are you
hi dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can we help
um i've got a uh
a judgment against me that i'm making
payments on
for a medical bill
i'm making a 50 payment that's the most
i can make um that added interest to the
uh
to the bill after judgment
uh so there's no interest on the actual
hospital bill so you actually got sued
and there's an actual judgment
yes two of them actually okay
so you're you then you did an agreement
with the court or with the attorney
and agree to order to pay payments
yes and how much is the judgment
uh the judgment is for uh six thousand
total i've already paid uh like two
thousand on it twenty five hundred on it
so is the balance now four thousand or
had interest out of that
uh the interest
was the it was the bill was originally 4
000. the interest was like 1600. um but
my payment what do you owe today sir
what do you owe today
uh 4500 that's what i'm asking okay and
what about the other one
the other one is 4 500 and it's recent i
haven't paid anything on it okay so
there's nine thousand dollars makes you
free
not debt free but free of judgments
great what do you make
2800 a year about 2400 a month
okay 28 000 a year okay
what do you do
uh i'm a parts advisor
here at a dealership
how old are you
20 or 32 sir
and i just i don't know what to do all
my money goes straight to the interest
and doesn't pay the debt
i think a1 is getting this income up
i think you can do better have you
looked at other jobs working overtime
doing side hustles
around here for
for this area is
there's not really too much work that
pays more or
you're in wichita kansas
yeah that's not true
this is not a tiny little town do you
have a walmart not a tiny little town
there's lots of places you can do things
i'm south of wichita about an hour
oh okay all right so it's a pretty rural
area yeah all right are you married
right on the oklahoma line uh no uh
engaged but not married okay is anything
keeping you there other than her
uh my kids i've got is with my ex-wife
okay all right
all right
so here here's the thing a really good
strong part-time job and it might mean
that weekends you go
drive north and stay in hotel room i
don't know
um
into wichita and get you know a really
great part-time job but a great
part-time job you could make ten
thousand dollars in six months
and just make and just make this go away
and george is exactly right the part of
the problem is you're on a really tight
budget you don't make a ton of money and
the long-term solution is to get your
income up long-term and the short-term
solution is to get your income up short
term
if we go find 10 grand we change your
life
right yeah yeah it wouldn't take much to
make my life a whole lot better but yeah
i can't because not a hundred grand it's
not 100 it's 10 grand
right and so there's legal action i
could take no there's no legal action
you got sued and you lost the lawsuit
because you owed the money okay and you
know there's no real i mean there's no i
mean you could file bankruptcy but if
i'm bankrupting 9000 is ludicrous
no you need to just go get you need to
go get some money
and i don't i don't know what the
easiest fastest way for you to have the
best possible paying part-time job in
your situation in a rural town in kansas
is
but it might be to drive into wichita
for the weekends and work weekends up
there and just bust your butt work like
14 hours a day 15 hours a day and i
don't care if you go up there i don't
care if you go up there and build decks
or you shovel sidewalks or or clean out
septic tanks i don't care what you do
but go get you some money over the next
six months and get this off of you
and that's the thing that that's the
only way i know how to do it um you
could also sell everything that isn't
tied down at this point too and try to
make some quick money that way
i gotta tell you
if you get married and uh the household
income is 32 000 that is half of the
annual average annual income in america
today
half
that puts you in the lower
lower income bracket
with two kids 32 000 is poverty level
in america today
according to the federal poverty
guidelines okay so i'm not picking on
you i'm shaming you i'm pointing out
that you need a better career long term
to have a better life
and that might entail you and your new
wife move
and you
you know you make some trips back to see
the kiddos
uh in order for you to have a much
better situation i don't know but it
sounds like you are convinced and i'm
not sure you're wrong that there's very
little long-term upside
around your area where you know in a
metro area right now
you make 32 000 bucks falling off a log
i mean it's
you know and you can make 60 000 if you
get out there and hustle so
uh doing something
and that's what i want for you i just
want you to have a better life uh and so
if there is not economic opportunity for
you
you may need to consider relocating as a
long-term thing and how you work that
with the kids from the former wife yeah
well there's not a lot of options we
need more options and if that means
moving i'm okay with that if it means
going around the neighborhood saying how
i'm on my lawns i'll walk dogs i'll do
whatever
to make some money right now i think
people will respect that and it could be
a short-term solution hustle and grind
that's one grind man it's the only way
to do it
and but that that's what i would do if i
were in your shoes if i woke up in your
shoes
i would be about to go crazy with work
and hard work won't kill you right
before you die you pass out don't worry
about it
so it's okay you're gonna be all right
uh and i don't think you're afraid of
hard work i think you just don't believe
you can find any and i want you to go
find some now
because that changes everything people
feel paralyzed just kind of beating
themselves down going well you got
yourself into this mess and we just
gotta go all right i got here but we can
get out we can get out of this if you're
in a situation where there is truly not
a lot of economic opportunity around you
there's not a lot of buzz
in the air
um
you know it's the polar opposite of a
big city and i don't want to live in a
huge city either i get that
and if you're used to living out in the
country you don't live in a city at all
i get that too
but you also have to be where there's
economic activity to have economic
activity and land in your pocketbook
land in your wallet yeah and so there's
some reality to that and you've got to
think about where it is you're going to
do and how you're going to do this
i stayed in nashville and ran this when
everybody told me and talk radio if i
didn't move to la or new york we'd never
make it
we proved them to be wrong on that
but we found a way to work around it
and still have the career
and we're the second largest talk radio
show in america today and we're out of
nashville not la or new york so it can
be done but you've got to really think
about how you're going to pull it off
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
thank you for joining us
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today our phone number is triple
eight eight two five five
two two five lee is with us in omaha
nebraska hi lee how are you
i'm doing well dave how about you better
than i deserve what's up
well i want to give you a little quick
history i talked to you about five years
ago after reading the money makeover at
that time i was three years away from
retirement
i called and told you that i had paid
off everything but my house and i wanted
to get an annuity in my ira to make my
house payment
and you advised me against that and told
me to take a withdrawal and pay off the
house
well against the advice of my friends i
did that so i've been debt free for the
last five years and it's a pretty darn
good feeling so i appreciate the advice
but
what's happening now is the same friends
are telling me i need an inflation hedge
and that i should withdraw money from my
ira and put money down on a couple of
rental properties so that they
increase in value over the next few
years
but my problem is i have quite a bit of
my ira in tips staggered so they come do
at different times
and i bonds so i'm making eight nine
percent now i'm only withdrawing three
so
my wife tells me why in the world would
you want to be a landlord and have leaky
toilets and calls in the middle of the
night and all that so
my question to you dave is do i listen
to my friends or do i listen to my wife
well that's a no-brainer
then we could talk about the advice too
but i mean
a proverb says who can find a virtuous
wife for her worth is far above rubies
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her and he will have no lack
of gain
if your wife isn't a nag and she is a
wise virtuous woman
her worth her wisdom is will cause you
to have no lack of gain as opposed to
stupid friends
and there's lots of people have stupid
friends i've got a few stupid friends so
i'm sitting next to one though no i
don't know george is not stupid george
has a lot of things but stupid is not on
the list but i i i
agree i think you can ignore your
friend's advice on this one and not
because your wife is right and they're
wrong but
because it's not it's not a wise move
for everyone now let's talk about it for
a second okay what is a hedge
against inflation a hedge is literally
like you think of a a row of bushes
right and tightly woven together so that
the neighbor's dog can't get through
right i mean it's it's a blocker
a hedge is a blocker a wall
to keep inflation from getting in
all inflation hedges
are investments that invest in things
that inflate with inflation
so real estate is a hedge against
inflation investing in companies whose
stock goes up and price goes up if the
inflation rate goes up uh would be a
hedge against inflation
energy company as an example
what happens what's a component of
inflation gas price at the pump right
right so if you buy a energy company you
have a hedge against inflation because
they're
they are inflation
and so you own a piece of inflation
thus it's a hedge real estate is
inflation
the rising real estate prices is a
component of inflation so that's a hedge
against inflation tips aren't
uh savings accounts aren't so if you
wanted to have a hedge against inflation
yes real estate would be a play
and a good one
yes
moving some of your
money into some mutual funds
that are investing in stocks of
companies
that are gaining due to inflation
so you are riding the wave of inflation
rather than being crushed by it that is
the definition of a hedge that's the
essence of it and so but aren't clips
tied to inflation so
they could be depends on what's in it
well i mean i own tips uh uh within my
ira but i bought they were purchased as
bonds so it's not a tips fund it's not
bonds are not
bonds are not because bonds are just a
debt instrument they've got a fixed
interest rate attached to them
and that is not maybe i'm using the
wrong term it's it's a treasury inflated
protected security right it's what it's
called a tip so i maybe it's a note
maybe bond is the wrong word well it is
a note and but it has a fixed coupon
rate that's why it's not a component of
inflation see if you think of okay
lumber went up 3x during covid right
went from 600 dollars per 100 600 per
board foot or whatever up up to about
1500
and so in that that is a component of
inflation and so if you owned
uh a stock in a lumber company if you
were participating in 84 lumber i don't
even know if it's publicly traded but if
it was and you owned in that then you
would be having a hedge against
inflation if you own
a note that 80 84 lumber company has
promised to pay 8 on
it doesn't change with inflation
but the price of lumber changes and that
company makes more money
so you got to be participating as an
owner not a lender
i see and that that's what moves so if
you're concerned about that i would move
some of my portfolio and i probably
would anyway into some good mutual funds
now if you want to buy some real estate
and you want to pay cash for it and buy
real estate that doesn't require a lot
of leaky toilets and midnight calls i
mean you can buy a little small piece
commercial a little office building a
little apartment or something have
somebody else manage it that'd be okay
what's the size of your net worth
uh
well total with house ira everything
probably eight hundred thousand eight
fifty way to go congratulations how old
are you well
i am i'll be 68 shortly
after hearing you talk i'm probably
going to sit exactly where you are i'm
with your wife
okay she's going to be glad to hear that
yeah because you like you like
predictability and
precision well i do i i don't like a lot
of risk in my investments and then uh
you know i
with the with the passive income i have
and the money i have in the ira i'm i'm
doing okay yeah so i just don't know
that it's worth the risk not knowing
what's going to be in the mailbox when
you open it is not your play
right right and it is for some people
it's not free well i mean i own rental
property and i don't know if they're
going to pay every month
sure
and that but you know these tips are
paying yeah that's a coupon it's just
gonna show up in the dad gum mailbox or
the electronic mailbox whatever i mean
your money's coming you can it's mailbox
money you can count on it so i i think
your life is good and i don't think i'd
screw with it
because of the way the way you think if
there's a few million here we might say
all right paying cash for something
that's what i'm looking for but 800 000
i don't think it's worth taking a huge
chunk of that out to buy real estate if
you're sitting on 2 million in that i
pull 500 out and move it towards some
kind of a commercial real estate and you
love real estate but real estate is not
for everyone and you don't need it to
build wealth and keep wealth no people
can do that with their mutual funds with
their 401ks and i agree with a lot of
things but you just need to do it with
something that that fits your profile
and he's got a very clear profile
and part of his profile is his friends
are not trustworthy
time to find new friends at 68. i don't
know you've had these friends for so
long
well it's just we're all sitting on the
front porch whittling with an opinion
about economics but yeah
uh yeah
[Music]
that's what friends are for that's what
wives are for too and husbands are for
it's good stuff we need them all very
good stuff
one of the keys to my wealth building
has been slowing down enough to make
sure my wife speaks into it sharon is
the best investment they've ever made
you heard it here first you did it's
absolutely 40 years now this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight
eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money
candace is up next candace is in tulsa
oklahoma hey candace how are you
hi dave i'm doing great it's so such an
honor to talk with you and george today
thank you so much you too what's up
so we recently were surprised with the
call
after my my husband's uncle passed away
earlier this year he had apparently put
my husband down as a beneficiary
beneficiary on a 401k he had
at a job
several years ago it wasn't the job he
had when he passed
so we um inherited the 401k it had about
50 000 in it at the time that the check
was cut to my husband
so i don't i've looked you know talked
to a few people i know some of the rules
things as far as an inherited 401k as to
distributions and all that i believe
it's within the first 10 years
everything needs to get withdrawn
i don't know
how that looks year to year and so i'm
just calling for your clarity on that
and then advice when we take those
distributions what we should do with the
money
um
well you have to take a tenth a year
you're correct
okay it's called the drain and 10 rule
and it passed the secure act uh
it was signed into law in december took
effect at the beginning of 2020 signed
into law but right before covet
how convenient but um yeah so
you used to take an inherited ira using
the old rmd rules the required minimum
distribution but now it's a drain intent
so you got you got good information you
got to take out a tenth every year until
it's gone uh then the only question of
what to do with it is wherever you are
on the baby steps right
right
so where are you guys at currently
so we don't have any debt but our home
and we have about 87 probably left on
the mortgage it's probably worth around
200.
we have about um so my husband husband's
a police officer so he has a defined
benefit plan so we don't contribute to
that it's just a pension um
so we don't have a 401ks side or any
other you know investments aside from
that pension as far as retirement you
should you need to be putting 15 of your
income into retirement do you have an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
we have about forty thousand dollars in
savings
um
not including exciting enough food
have you heard of our baby steps
that we talk about right here
yes sir
so i think we need to get the emergency
fund up you have no debt except the
house so the next step would be fully
funding that emergency fund to three to
six months which is probably somewhere
10 to 15 000 for you guys at least
all right so we have 40 already 40
thousand dollars you said you had three
thousand you have an extra three in a
different account
no i'm sorry we have forty thousand
dollars in a savings account what was
the three thousand you mentioned
i'm sorry i didn't i didn't mean to say
3 000 if i said that okay i did hear
that didn't it i i heard it too okay so
yeah then we would be investing 15 and
you could use part of this money to
fully fund a roth ira if you're under
the income limits what's your household
income
uh about 92. perfect housing a year yeah
do a couple of roth iras are your first
thing
you ought to be doing that out of your
budget anyway and just be sitting down
doing a budget and putting 15 of your
income into retirement
that's baby step four do you have
children
we have four children and we haven't we
haven't started anything with the
college baby step five is kids college
and with anything above
the 15 going into retirement and above
what you do to kids college you throw
that at the house so it sounds to me
like a fourth or a tenth of
fifty thousand is going to be five
thousand that's going to help you get
baby steps four and five going
okay
that's what it sounds like i appreciate
it yeah you see how we're doing that so
you need to sit down with a smartvestor
pro and start working on this and
figuring out what you're going to move
where you're going to move it what it's
going to be invested in and
you know get you get something started
for the kids college even if it's 50
bucks a piece a month get a little
something going so you get so you start
building the college muscle
and then you go ahead and make sure
you're putting 15 of your income into
retirement and this 5 000 a year is
going to just going to help you
do those things that's all
so hey good question we appreciate you
joining us open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five jacob
is in north dakota hi jacob welcome to
the ramsey show
hi how are you guys better than we
deserve how can we help
yeah so my wife is currently in med
school and we are cash flowing it right
now um
i just have a question because my mom
i was i was very fortunate i was put
mostly to school through her 529
and she has some leftover money in it
and
it was just in my name but she was
wondering if she kind of wants to
withdraw it and she's wondering if she
can use it to pay for my wife's med
school and then we pay her back
i don't know though if that's
allowed or not
or how that works i would not i would
not do the deal because i'm not paying
her back
you don't want to be in debt to your
mother
well we could we could pay her back like
immediately no we we have the money
sitting but i just don't know
if it's legal basically
oh wait she's gonna give you twenty
thousand dollars and you're gonna give
her twenty thousand dollars yeah
how did this benefit you it didn't
no but it would uh so she would
basically be withdrawing of 529 without
paying the penalties
yeah without paying any taxes
yeah
so it's just a favor to her
yeah
well that's sweet
um
i
[Applause]
you're gonna have to check a tax advisor
because the nuances in the law you can
you use a 529 now for anyone in your
immediate family i do not know if we can
consider this immediate family or not i
don't know the answer
i'm sitting here also questioning
whether i'm screwing with this or not
but how much money is this
about 30 uh
is what she would be asking yeah okay so
you have thirty thousand dollars in an
account she's gonna write you a check
for 30 out of the 529
to pay or pay for school for 30 and then
you're gonna give her that money right
back
and you're not going to be right you're
not going to be in debt to her okay
no it seems it seems like a tax
efficient move
um
she certainly can share it with her son
i don't know where the break point is if
her son is 60 and she's 80 can you do
that i don't know if there's a cut off
on the day on the age i'm not saying
you're 16 she's saying i'm just saying
these are grown people these aren't
traditional students so
i yeah i thought it was 30 somewhere but
i need to look look into that yeah the
numbers on that start poking around
there uh while i'm
why weren't you poking around there
while i was stammering but anyway
i slow to the punch
but uh i the truth is i just don't know
the answer question jacob um
and i i was gonna question
whether or not it ought to be done but i
don't hear any problems with the way
whether it ought to be done i think i
would do it
if you can but you need to get
uh she needs to get reassurance
that she is not
it's not illegal it's not a it's not a
criminal thing it's just a matter of
whether in the event of an audit would
this be disallowed
would this be considered outside the law
outside the tax law so it's just a tax
question it's not really a criminal
legal question
um it's just uh is this an improper use
of a 529 that would be disallowed in the
event of an audit
um and i don't know what the cutoff is i
know you're allowed to share the new 529
rules a couple years ago that came in i
used to be siblings could share it but
now you literally can use your kids
529 for you to go to school
if your kids don't use it
i mean so it's anywhere in the family it
goes any direction back and forth so i
kind of think you can that's i think
when you dig into it you're going to
find that did you find anything well i'm
just seeing that the earnings portion of
any unspent funds after the beneficiary
turns 30 are subject to 10 penalty but
that doesn't include if you change
beneficiaries and what that would mean
to the age limits yeah so i jump on
ramsey solutions. sounds like if it
sounds like if you're under 30 because
you definitely could share it with your
wife you might have to roll it
you might have to put it in a 529 in
your name from her name
in order for you to share it with your
wife because she's not blood ken to your
wife that might be the the catcher um
check with your investment broker and or
a um
uh you know a smart vester pro if you're
working with one or uh a tax pro and you
can get those at elp for tax pro as well
at ramsey solutions i'm sorry i just
don't that's a weird little corner of
the world i don't know the answer that
little nuanced thing
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage douglas and janan are
with us hey guys how are you we're good
how are you better than we deserve where
you all live
raleigh north carolina raleigh awesome
great town welcome to nashville thank
you and here to do a debt-free scream
how much did you pay off 130 000 good
for you how long did that take 39 months
all right and your range of income
during that time uh 175 to 200. cool
what do y'all do for a living we both
work in the insurance industry great
very good what kind of uh debt was the
130 000
um we had student debt
car debt we were kind of poor car poor
for a while we were definitely upside
down on two cars and um credit cards
yeah ah okay how much of the 130 was
cars
uh
close to that would have been forty
forty eight thousand ah okay a bunch of
it yeah cool so what happened 39 months
ago that put you on this journey to the
ramsey way
we met some awesome people that were
debt free and we got together and
started doing a group
and that really helped motivate us but
more than that we were just tired of
arguing about money
and so when this group was presented and
they're just awesome supports and we
just said that this is where we want to
be and we're so excited that we
accomplished it perfect financial peace
university class or just a group yeah no
it was it was the class itself okay but
we continue to meet once a month i mean
they're
you know we're still meeting even now
that we're we're debt-free and moving
into the next step good um i love it and
it's yeah so you guys became close yes
yeah wow what did this group start like
in a church or was this friends that
decided to do this friends friends wow
that's awesome so you went hey these
people are debt-free maybe they could uh
show us the way absolutely that and dave
ramsey wow awesome well we're honored
very cool you guys
very cool so you've been working on this
a little over three years that's a long
journey
yeah at the time we thought oh my
goodness it's going to take us forever
it it just kind of came and it went so
quickly that you know it's awesome that
we stayed with it and now we're on the
next journey so what was the hardest
part
probably getting on the same page um
probably like looking and saying hey
you know how much debt do we really have
and how much we kept a secret the
communication the communication piece in
the in the beginning i think we we had
our head in the sand and we didn't
really want to talk about what we both
knew were issues with our finances and
when we started the class we finally
started to have open communications and
and that's really it's improved our
marriage but it's also really improved
our direction um as far as our financial
journey is concerned wow so where did
that come from this kind of hiding hey i
don't want to be upfront and totally
honest about this was there just shame
shame and baggage associated with these
decisions yeah no i think it was shame
as as much as anything
wasn't free and it was easier it was
easier not to talk about it so
i didn't worry about it much when we
weren't talking about it
of course
but then there was some freedom it
sounds like and just saying all right
it's on the table here it is we're going
to attack this together absolutely and
it was nice to see that she was being as
bad as i was so
made you feel better thanks well now
that you've told me i've got one for you
oh my god and i see yours and i raise
you a mastercard
yeah what was the most surprising thing
about the journey for you guys as you
started paying off debt so i guess the
one thing that we want to make sure we
tell on our journey is he was diagnosed
with a very serious medical condition
last year and so
it really didn't put us off track but we
kept looking back going oh my goodness
if we would have been in debt and had
this extra amount that we had to pay a
tremendous amount of money for medical
we probably wouldn't have made it
through because we would have been
fighting all the time and it was just
been so stressful
and so i guess that's the biggest story
we like to tell people and from the time
of my diagnosis to um
to the to the end of debt-free um we
actually paid more the last year um than
we did the first two years we we we just
it it gave us a focus
um that i don't know we would have had
otherwise and uh um this just got real
yeah it did so but wow how are you doing
now i'm doing well good good i'm glad to
hear that
good stuff so now that you've been in a
group and you are successful you paid
off 130
000
that's amazing
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
to stick with it and just you know i say
do small goals because i'm a
goal-oriented person
so i'm always saying okay set those
goals you know and then when you
accomplish it get to the next goal so to
me it was always
fun i guess if you called being in debt
and credit card debt fun but um
attraction
you hit the next one and then you'd be
like okay our next goal is this and you
know we'd be like hey do we go out to
eat this weekend and we're like no she's
all about she's all about getting to the
next number and so so even to the point
that we would we would rob ourselves of
of other things that we maybe was going
to use that money for just to get to
that next number i like it um
it's because well intensity right it
built some momentum yeah we listened to
that a lot on that group that's our
favorite video by the way
that's pretty incredible well done y'all
very cool so i'm seeing three things
here that stood out to me you said you
need a goal
you need a plan and you need other
people yeah and when you have those
three things i mean you just feel
invincible you could run through a wall
and these people are still with you
today i assume is this like a cheer
squad you brought it
i don't think i have that many friends
that's impressive
good for you guys i think the support is
huge through this and and
you know there's there's people in this
group that have made some of the same
dumb mistakes we made and to be able to
see that someone had made those mistakes
and found their way out of the hole um
it gave us you know it gave us a road
map and it was
it's been great through the whole
process yeah way to go you guys
congratulations we're proud of you thank
you well done heroes well done got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too
we've also got a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away to someone
and uh financial peace university
membership for a year and you can give
that to someone since you guys have
already got a group and doing it that's
cool because a lot of fpu groups become
lifelong friends it's not unusual at all
and the coordinators particularly become
lifelong friends with the people in the
group so very cool congratulations you
guys well done thank you douglas and
janan in raleigh north carolina 130 000
paid off in 39 months making 175 the 200
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three
two
[Applause]
it feels like life always happens on the
debt-free journey
very rarely someone like it was just
smooth there's always some big hiccup
but it's it almost feels apropos because
you go this is why we're doing this back
back in the day when we were starting
financial peace university and i was
still leading
the classes teaching them live before
video and all that stuff we would always
just tell people when they joined the
class um one of the things you need to
know as soon as you join the class your
transmission's going to go out
i mean because like the number of people
that came through the class in the old
days and their transmission would just
fall out of the car it was unbelievable
it's like there's always something going
to come at you to test you
like to see if you're really going to do
this
it's like the devil is testing to see if
you're really going to work god's plan
you know it's like this is a test of the
emergency money network i mean it's like
you're just going to check you see if
you're real or not yeah and man they had
a real test there because medical is a
lot of scary that's a lot bigger than
transmissions for sure
a lot bigger deal very cool very very
cool well done you guys hey george and
rachel cruz and i along with dr john
dolone and ken coleman will be doing
live events this fall and they're just
about all sold out uh we've got a little
bit of seats left in phoenix on
september the
12th the 13th is already sold out
sacramento sold out november the 1st
minneapolis november the 10th in san
antonio november the 15th i think
there's 20 seats left there so wow
it's not many
if you want to come to these building
wealth events uh that's the dates
they're september and they're november
and we would love to have you they're
only 25 to come for the night and a four
pack starting as low as 60
do like those folks in the debt free
scream get some friends come to the
first time come on
and people are loving this we'll be
signing books taking pictures hanging
out with you guys as well as talking to
you about building
wealth these events sell out very very
quickly just a handful of seats left at
all of them please get your tickets
immediately buildingwealth
ramseysolutions.com
events
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality
open phones are triple eight eight two
five five two two five he's my co-host
today ryan is with us in atlanta hi ryan
welcome to the ramsay show
hello how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um so basically i was just kind of came
in contact with your show after um
a whole life insurance seller was trying
to get me to buy that and i watched a
few year videos and basically have been
ignoring him since then
it got me thinking about down one down
oh he's called me about seven or eight
times since then but he made a whole
portfolio for me which was nice of him
um just use the block feature
yeah well it's kind of nice watching the
ring um
basically i'm just kind of in the side
too trying to figure out what i want to
do
with
my extra cash until i go back to school
just by the house
so i do have a mortgage as of now first
time home buyer
i have about 15 000 on my car left but i
have about 65 000 um in the bank right
now
and i just i
never really have been introduced into
the financial world
um so i'm not really sure what i need to
start doing
do you have any other debt other than
the car on the mortgage
uh no
what's your income
um so mine kind of fluctuates with my
job
since i'm kind of a travel nurse
right now this year it'll be probably
about 120 to 130. what's the uh beyonce
what's the go back to school
uh i want to get my phd and keep going
to school i love education so it's just
it's more of a personal goal for me and
it will also brought my scholar up to
about 180 to 190 depending on where i am
do you have the money to pay for school
that are i have the 65 000 and that is
it right now
i do have a fiancee that works right now
she makes uh right at six figures
and um so it would basically be between
that and probably student loan sadly
when are you guys getting married
uh april of this coming year um
most of the wedding stuff is already
paid for and planned i probably still
have another seven eight thousand
dollars put down on the wedding
um that i'm just expecting i'm sure some
unexpected costs will come up and when
does school
start um i'm i still have to get
accepted but my attendance plan um is
hopefully false 2023 um but i'm going to
keep applying until i get back okay so
you'll be making
do you if you go back and start working
on your phd is that an adult education
thing where you keep working
i cannot keep working into it it's a
crna program which is nurse anesthesia
and a lot of programs will not let you
work while you're doing it because it is
basically full-time um summer's winners
everything yeah it's a two-year deal
right
at three years three okay
she'll be living off her income for
three years at that point
at that point yes sir which is about a
hundred thousand
she made i think before taxes 115.
okay
so here's um
what i would do if i were in your shoes
and you're fairly new to our stuff uh
but we've been teaching this stuff
around ramsey for about 30 years now
and basically the question we're always
trying to ask is what is the shortest
distance
between where you are
and wealthy
and uh not because rich is everything or
something like that but
you know what is the the fastest right
path
now not the shortest distance but the
fastest right path that doesn't bankrupt
you or put you at high risk or something
like that so what we do know
is
that um
the number one
key to wealth building is to free up
your largest wealth building tool which
is your income so avoiding debt and
getting out of debt and staying out of
debt is going to be a solid tenant that
all of our data and experience leads us
to
so in your situation what does that mean
it means i'm paying off your car today
okay now you're debt-free but the house
okay yes sir um and then when you all
are married you're gonna have a 200 000
plus
your income until you go back to school
i'm going back to school when i can map
out how
between my income now and her income
later we can live in cash flow school no
debt
nurse anesthesia is a great career field
the roi on that degree is excellent in
most cases
uh yes i strongly recommend you do this
not just because you like education but
because you will make a lot of money for
the money you spend
however having said that you know and i
know that the school you can go to
there's a wide spectrum of expenses
you can go to the expensive nurse
anesthesia school or you can go to the
not expensive one you're gonna go to the
not expensive one since you're paying
cash even if you get accepted only to
the expensive one you're going to apply
to the non-expensive one until you get
in
okay a lot of people in your shoes feel
so honored and i finally got into this
very difficult program and they let me
in and they're going to charge me so
much that my grandchildren will still be
in debt
but it's a great honor bull crap
it is not a great honor
you just got screwed that's what that is
and that happens in the medical field
every day dude i've worked with md's and
nurses for 30 years that regretted where
they chose to go get their degree
because i got to tell you right before
they stick a needle in my arm before
they put before you put me under i have
never once asked one of you people where
you went to school
would you sacrifice where you're living
and yeah actually where you're rooted in
right now to go to the cheaper school
yes
the two schools in georgia have about a
hundred and fifty thousand dollar
tuition difference yeah there you go
they are both racial yeah i made you
just made my case yes
yes
and neither one
train people to kill people
you know in both cases you can you know
you you can administer anesthesia safely
i mean oh my god and in both cases
you're going to come out making 400k i
mean it's a sweet ride you're signing up
for i
totally endorse your path
but just the the way you go about your
path use some freaking wisdom
yes sir and you do that man you're gonna
be you're gonna be lining up this thing
up so it's pretty simple you all make a
couple of hundred a year
uh you get the cars paid off for you
guys you know you pile up money you just
stack cash and then you get married you
stack more cash and if you start spring
of 24 instead of fall of 23 and you go
to the right school you can cash flow
what i'm talking about here you got the
money coming in you stack the cash i can
hear the numbers
and our plan if i did go of course and
i'm hoping to go to the least expensive
school was to rent out basically the
house that we just bought now i've
already looked in our hoa they do allow
rentals
and basically so we won't have to sell
this keep the property fine or be okay
to sell mortgage be okay to sell it
there's a lot of houses a lot of houses
in atlanta you can get one when you come
back you're gonna be gone three years
and while you're studying while you've
got your nose in the books you may not
want to be screwing with renters i don't
know
and so what about the cash that i have
now so just keep saving it or let's
start pay off the car pay off the car
today and stack cash we're going to
we're going to go get our we're going to
go be a nurse anesthetist and we're
going to pay cash for it and i got to
stack cash my whole life for the next 18
months is stacking cash
that works for me i can eat chicken and
rice daily hey man game on here you're
right on because see you come out
with no debt
dude with what you're going to be making
what she's going to be making as young
as y'all are you're going to be so
freaking rich it's going to be
unbelievable
yeah that's kind of what we're hoping
for yeah because you didn't you didn't
handcuff yourself yeah and you put
yourself in shackles
the shackles of slavery
on the way in i've got family who's
doing the crna program now in med school
and seeing the amount of debt they are
in i can't breathe we're talking half a
million dollars in debt
so seeing his situation where it's very
much possible to cash flow this whole
experience and be making 350 household
income with no debt it changes
everything yep absolutely
absolutely so here's the thing
uh hang on we're gonna sign you up for
uh financial peace university you and
your fiance go through as our guest
and uh we'll figure out what we're doing
then so sign up for financial peace
university hang on austin will pick up
and we'll get you doing that as a as a
wedding pres early wedding present get
you guys going in the right direction
so
it's incredible well i think we saved
him from whole life and med school debt
who knew it could happen all in one day
that's pretty cool i think we actually
cut that one that's incredible i think i
heard the like our work is done for the
day we've done a good deed i think we
did our job for the day and saving them
from whole life might be the i mean that
just makes me happy oh that is great
those guys will pester you to no end
that's just so fun
there's a lot of fun going on in that
call
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us america we're glad you're
here phone number is triple eight eight
two five
five two two
five you jump in and we'll talk james is
in chicago hi james how are you
hello sir how are you doing today better
than i deserve how can we help
i love that that's a great line better
than i deserve
so i'll be honest uh probably two and a
half years ago i've never heard your
name
and uh and then i just watched some
videos
uh about you talking directly to
americans and i'm like wow that guy
seems to
to get it and um
i'm not uh i only listen to you when
when i'm in my car
when i'm driving but i i just want to
ask you a couple questions
specifically about term life insurance
okay uh unless i'm mistaken i think that
you and i believe
that that term life insurance is is
uh a much far better option than
permanent or whole
insurance um and that being said
um
the world of term life insurance has has
changed a lot in the past
uh
several years uh we now have platforms
you can go on and and ostensibly get
approved for life insurance
in in 30 40 minutes
maybe you know
24 hours or 40 hours no medical exams no
blood
and uh
and and then of course you can get a
fully underwritten policy
and and the consumer
uh the consumer you know i i believe
needs to to to be able to ask and answer
questions about what's important to them
if they don't care about
the getting a policy and doing paperwork
in 90 days then that's fine but if they
need insurance for whatever reason today
or tomorrow
then these these kind of instant
decision instant approval policy today
signed today
options are better
i guess my question dave again i would
say you've forgotten more about term
life insurance than i know
um
but but uh my sense is that um
that that maybe the the the the the
policies are are different you know the
exact same company the exact same
carrier and and and and get a instant
decision or
simplified issue 48 days
40 minutes whatever
and it's really like
a a premium question how much are you
willing to pay right so that you don't
have to have the doctor come in you
don't have to have the nurse
practitioner come in and and and you
might be willing to pay more and the
last thing i'll let you talk is
my sense of it is that um because i've
got four children
and
that that these gen z's and millennials
uh don't want to you know deal with
paperwork and brokers and and and going
into a broker's office as you probably
remember when you were when i think
we're probably the similar age um
and doing everything online is of high
value
to to gen z and millennials and they're
they may be willing to pay more um and
not have to go through all that regular
i'm very curious as to what your
thoughts are yeah well uh yeah you're
exactly right the market is moving that
way
um
and and the reason that the uh no
medical and no underwriting policies are
higher
in most cases they almost always are is
because
obviously the life insurance companies
taking more risk
because they're going to get some sick
people in the pile
and so they're they're going to their
risk is higher so they're they're going
to charge more premiums for that that's
what it amounts to
um
and you're right but and and here's the
problem the insurance the life insurance
industry is still very antiquated in
general
and uh the the their ability to gather
data
from multiple sources on you medically
and you know make a quick decision with
actual real medical data i mean you may
have had blood work in the last little
while doing your you know doing your
annual physical but they won't use that
they got to send out their own little
guy
and their ability to think outside of
that and just pull it all together and
make a quick decision with actual data
and a low premium
is probably not too far in the future
because the ability to pull data with
your permission on you from several
sources without you having to
have a medical exam a physical medical
exam to get life insurance and their
ability to underwrite the thing without
going through the laborious manual tasks
that they do
is in the not too distant future and
because and we know that because the
companies because as you said the
uh the generation that has grown up with
a magic wand in their hand
called a cell phone that when you push a
button stuff happens
does not like when you push a button and
things don't happen
and it takes a while it takes 90 days
and you have to go through an
underwriting process and so someone's
going to solve for this
and uh and they're going to charge for
it but but it's going to be the person
who gets a lot of business and so we're
in talks with many different
life insurance carriers through xander
having a lot of different discussions
about these exact things right now
because we've seen the writing on the
wall for some time on this and
and we're con trying our best to
convince them that the first one of this
party is going to really have a good
time yeah um and so in the meantime
though you do have the more instant
issues like he's talking about the
people who instantly issue it at a
higher premium would i do that no that's
playing shortfall yeah that's just being
impatient and paying too much i recently
went through this experience to re-up my
life insurance through xander and it was
interesting to play around with the
quotes and i just did it here for fun
and up to about a million dollars of
coverage there are a lot of touchless
experience no medical exam required at
very competitive rates so i will say
they've come a long way and so it's
worth going to our website and click on
xander and go for yourself and check out
the quotes and some of them are going to
be very reasonable with no medical exam
if you're in good health so they have
preferred preferred plus if you're in
one of those tiers that's when you're
going to have a competitive rate but if
you do have health issues there's no way
and you lie about them the insurance is
invalid exactly it's called fraud so
we're not talking about that but if you
are in good health and you want to go
with this route so i mean if you're
doing a new medical and you know you
have a medical
and your doc knows you have a medical
problem and you don't claim it
and you go take a preferred rate as if
there's nothing wrong with you that's
called fraud they will not pay on that
when you die
so don't screw around with it you're not
going to fool them yeah don't screw
around with this it's not a it's not a
thing you can shyster your way into have
some integrity but um
but yeah james is on to something there
he he's uh he obviously knows the
business and knows the vibe of what's
going on but
for today i would not pay substantially
more if we can get you through zander if
we can get you an instant
uh or a quick you know with no medical
and you don't have to lie to get it
don't don't be defrauding somebody and
it's a competitive rate then yeah that's
fine there's no advantage for that
especially when it's a name
like protective or aig or some you know
something i'm looking at right here
lincoln those are all major names as a
millennial let me speak you know they
came to the house they took the blood it
was no big deal
i i understand i'm an amazon prime
member too i like convenience but this
wasn't a big deal so get it done it's
worth it
you heard it here first there it is
there's your testimonial
they came to the house they took the
blood this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're so happy you're with
us thanks for being here hey parents
there's a lot you can't control you
can't control inflation you can't
control the economy you sure as crap
can't control washington but you can
control how you teach your teens
to face life
and the sooner they learn the better the
best thing you can teach your teen this
year is how to handle their money the
right way like how to budget how to save
how to spend wisely how to be generous
how to stay out of debt and foundations
in personal finance our high school
curriculum is in home school form as
well
it'll give your teens the tools they
need to win with money
to pay cash for college and stay out of
debt it's not just another homeschool
curriculum it's completely changing how
teens think about money and it can
change how your teen thinks too
so this school year give your teens the
money skills they'll need now and for
the rest of their lives with foundations
in personal finance go to
ramseysolutions.com
homeschool that'll get you there our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee and that means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free
if you screw up they'll fix it for you
that's pretty cool you got free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
window blinds the best there is
blinds.com great company use the promo
code the magic word ramsay
today's question comes from annabelle in
louisiana
she says i'm from louisiana and the one
thing i know for sure is that i don't
plan to retire here other than personal
preference what are the most important
financial considerations to look at in
potential states to retire in any
guidance would be greatly appreciated
that's a great question
so she's looking as southern as you can
get annabelle from louisiana
oh my god i love that that's fabulous
sweet tea
um
what do you think well i'm i think about
things like income tax of course and the
other side of that is property taxes
because those can be very expensive
depending on where you live
so i would factor those two into my
equation also looking at quality of life
you know you don't want to just live
somewhere because you know alaska may be
great well she said she said the most
important financial considerations i
assume she's going to
you know want to live in a nice area as
well something she likes the mountains
she'll be in a mountain range you know
that kind of thing like the ocean should
be near the ocean whatever it is that
you know that you want to be around in
your retirement years
the first thing that comes to mind is if
you hate the place go ahead and move
don't wait till retirement to be happy
okay that's silly
um just make your life somewhere else
don't spend two thirds of your life
somewhere you hate there's so many
things so there's so many possibilities
for me to disagree with something in
tennessee but i love this state
i have no desire to live anywhere else i
really do i love
so much about it and only part of that
is because of the financial reasons
right financially but i'm out it's just
beautiful i mean there's some it's a
diverse everything i like it there's a
lot going on here so a big fan of my
state so but if i wasn't i would leave
you know i hate chicago but i'm going to
stay in chicago my whole life well don't
do that i hate louisiana leave if you
love chicago stay in chicago if you hate
it leave i mean something for everyone
yeah there's just don't don't don't do
that so that financial consideration as
though georgia's right you want to check
your tax issues
um there are some states that just make
it
unpleasant to live there by the time
they tax your butt off
uh but uh do you want to name one dave i
know what you're thinking
connecticut mind reader connecticut
uh california yeah i can think of a few
new york yeah people leave new york all
the time because of it so as a matter of
fact we've seen a million people leave
new york and the migration and
california just those two states in the
last um
in the last 18 months or so during the
past so
pandemic adding to the crap so but uh uh
our political garbage around the
pandemic not even the pandemic it wasn't
like the pandemic was worse there just
the government was more stupid there
and so um anyway
there's that that's another
consideration is um
how the uh the the government behaves
in in that state as to whether you want
to live there because you're going to
have all kinds of
uh law and order issues you're going to
have in your retirement years you're
going to have
uh
uh issues of personal freedoms like
medical freedoms and those kinds of
things i would consider all of that
where i'm gonna live too uh period but
retirement for sure yeah stay out of an
income tax state there's no reason to be
in one there's plenty of states that are
don't have an income tax florida texas
tennessee are three of the big ones that
people have been moving to lately
they also have been
you know alabama mississippi even and so
lots of these states have benefited uh
from
the uh the the migration that's occurred
but it's all been tax based so look at
the income tax i'd look at inheritance
tax probate tax if you're gonna die and
leave a will during that time i mean how
they go how much are they gonna tax the
the size of your estate if you've built
up an estate to retire in um
sales tax is an issue it's not as big an
issue but it is
a few places it's a little crazy and uh
the interesting thing is that retirement
you tend to spend less so that sales tax
is not as punitive as income tax um so
uh you do want to look at that uh you do
look at cost of living you know um cost
of housing that's a financial
consideration so uh
you know the most expensive real estate
probably in the united states today is
probably still uh silicon valley and
manhattan um in terms of the and so very
difficult to want to retire in one of
those two areas
very few people would consider that a
retirement community uh so but but it's
cost of real estate that's driving that
uh super super expensive
uh and certainly other areas that are
high too and are making themselves
untenable
but yeah look at all of that and
then you know
as a ratio against how much you have
but i know guys i know three people
before covid
before the great migration
that are billionaires all three of them
and all three of them
paid cash for their home
multi-million dollar homes and one of
them was a lot of money in nashville
for the taxes that they saved in one
year from leaving california wow all
three of them left california
to not pay income tax there anymore
billionaires and all three of them paid
cash for
you know 10 to 30 million dollar houses
and uh that was the savings in one year
wow from being from moving and so that's
uh and all of them in their 60s 70s and
80s you know that kind of thing so
that's that those are retirement moves
um that were happening prior to covet
and uh
two of those three and uh you would
recognize a lot of people recognize
their names if i said them
and one of them bought a very
recognizable house if i said the
person's house that they bought uh it
would you know a country music house in
other words and so um
that kind of stuff so that's the kind of
thing that you're looking at and that's
the the economics affects
and taxation
is uh sometimes people think that you
can tax people
and you know we're just going to tax you
no because they leave they're not going
to be there to get taxed
and the people that leave are the ones
that pay the taxes that you thought you
were going to get when you passed that
law
and so the people that are left are the
people that don't pay much taxes so in
yourself on the field it really doesn't
work
when in a state situation uh united
states you know you gotta decide if you
want to leave the united states of
america or not if you don't like that
tax that's different that's expatriating
right but to decide to not live in new
york or california is a fairly easy
decision um
i had an email from a mutual friend this
morning uh
uh that was saying you know he said i'm
i'm i'm gone i'm done
i'm like well
time to migrate i understand so yeah
that's what you're looking for that's
what's driven this
by the way it is politics it is
policy it is a way of looking at things
but there's
when you run a pro forma if you're a
politician and you think oh we can just
raise taxes on the rich um you make the
assumption the rich are going to stay
and we've seen that with businesses too
and it doesn't work that way the
businesses pick up and leave for the
rich get up the economy it's the people
you thought you you know we're gonna tax
the rich they don't stay they move elon
said peace out i'm going to texas yeah
yeah a bunch of other people did yeah
yeah exactly what he said and i guess
yeah that's it so that that's what you
do when you're retiring it's the exact
same thing annabelle you're just looking
at those kinds of things and we got room
in tennessee annabelle if you're if
you're interested yeah but i i really i
wouldn't wait until i retire to be happy
or to love the place i love good life
advice this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage is
alexis
welcome alexis how are you i'm good cool
so what's your shirt say we were trying
to read it from in here and couldn't see
it it says melanated educated and
debt-free melanated yes the heel of my
skin oh
wow i like it
melanated educated and debt-free good
i'm in good for you well done how much
do you pay off
i paid uh 43 000 and 22 months good for
you where do you live i live in dallas
cool
and uh what's your range of income
during that 22 months started at 51.5
got up to 79 with all of the jobs back
at about 74. i'm still working like two
and a half jobs right now wow wow look
at you you get it so what was your best
side hustle the one that made the most
money
probably the uber eats and the doordash
under that was tutoring so i did tutor
oh fun what are you tutoring i tutor
english language arts i was a special
education teacher for about five years
still working education and was a great
way to put my skills to use cool cool
what do you do now what's your main job
i'm a student disability services
director at a university in texas cool
what's university texas a m commerce go
lions
oh i like it good for you good stuff fun
fun fun so what kind of debt was the 43
000
medical debt i had a car loan i had
student loans i had loans for loans
basically every loan
loans had loans my loans had a loan
a bed i had a bed yes anything
a cell phone
everything you were just norm yes i was
of course
sucks so how old are you i am 31 okay
and so you woke up 22 months ago in your
20s
29 years old and you said this didn't
work how'd you get connected to the
ramsey way what happened tell me your
story uh actually i had a friend who
posted a screenshot from the instagram
page and it was a lady she was holding a
sign and she was standing um in the er
and she had her number on it her number
was six figures and i didn't know my
number but i knew that it wasn't six
figures and i thought man i can do this
so i went to the page
i followed like started listening to the
podcast bought the book and i was in
from from jump i i just i went in wow
so the book being total money makeup yes
the total okay and then this podcast you
plugged into and that's how you did it
yes wow
you never know about an instagram i know
so you by number you mean you saw the
amount of debt she had paid off yes
i don't even know how much debt i'm in i
gotta look into this and then you got
sickened after you saw the number is
that what happened yes well i had you
know instances where i had more month
than money i was a teacher so i'm a type
a person i like organization things to
be in its place but i wasn't like that
with my money like my money was a mess
and i felt like i was working too hard
but i didn't have anything to show for i
grew up on payday loans housing and
security so i really never saw these
things so i had already been getting
tired i tried the budget with the excel
spreadsheet i suck at excel
so
you know i learned about the app which
was so easy for me to ever
download and i was just ready i just
went in wow where'd it go where'd it go
you killed it
do you how does it feel it feels good
like just to even come out here and to
have the money to do all of this like
that would have not happened 22 months
ago it probably would have been on the
credit card so just to be able to do the
things that i want to do
i mean it feels great yeah
you got to feel like accomplished
oh yeah definitely like you beat some of
your demons down right yeah i feel like
i can't be stopped like you can't tell
me anything amen i like it i preach it i
like it i like it i like it so did you
grow up in a household that was financed
you said finance you said housing
insecurity so there's financial issues
there when you're growing up yes i had a
single mother um i and and it was two of
us and you know she had a hard time just
keeping things in place not that she
didn't want to but no she didn't have
the resources yeah it's tough it's tough
but uh but so that's kind of ringing in
the back of your head and you're running
like your arizona fire away from that
yes that gives you some intensity right
definitely yeah good for you i'm so
proud of you did you have cheerleaders
were family proud of you for doing this
i mean you changed everything yeah i had
a lot of friends and co-workers this was
kind of like a lonely journey i stopped
telling people just at one point because
you do get the crazy looks
but i did have like my mom my friends um
different co-workers my church friends
who definitely just encouraged me prayed
for me throughout the way took me out to
lunch
you know did the things that i couldn't
do for myself yeah so next time the
crazy look people are around just make
sure you wear that t-shirt
that's like nan
and they're like wait you did what now
how'd you do that i said what i'm
listening it freezes i like it i like it
i like it good for you all right what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of that is the budget so the cash
envelopes i still have that's like my
second bible the budget is key and
changing your mindset so i really had to
change my mindset that you know i i can
make more money you know more money is
out there but i have to go and get it i
remember my church praying to be praying
to be debt free but i didn't see that
for myself or i thought that if it
happened that god would just give it to
me and know like you have to work for it
so that would be my two
look it turns out if you want corn you
got to plant some exactly
good for you well done well done well
done
well done i'm so proud of you
good work very very good work completely
changed everything 31 year old right
there it reminds me the quote from you
dave pray like it all depends on god
work like it all depends on you
and you did a good bit of both there and
there's an interesting relationship
between the two
it's awesome very very good all right
alexis we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story for sure
and uh how how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth how you can to
financial peace university sounds like
you haven't done that yet so maybe you
need to do that we've got a one-year
membership and george and rachel dr john
deloney are also featured on the videos
with me this time they just came out new
ones and uh the best we've ever done
total money makeover you can give that
to one of those people giving you the
side eye
and uh maybe they'll help you get going
like it helped you get going back then
so we'll give you an extra copy of it to
give away so great great job well done
kiddo all right alexis from dallas texas
43 000 paid off in 22 months making 51
to 79 to
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream thank you jesus three two one
[Applause]
change your family tree
change your history
to where never
again never again
never again that's powerful you know
when you look back on your childhood or
you look back on that hard time i mean
like when sharon and i were going
through bankruptcy american express
calls my house asked my wife why she
would stay with a man wouldn't pay his
bills
i said that's the last time
anybody in this branch of the ramsey
family is going to have to endure this
not only we're going to get out of debt
not only are we going to build wealth
we're going to teach the next generation
it's the last time the chains are broken
we're never going back and that's what
she's looking at in her rearview mirror
and her mom's worked her mom worked her
tail off did everything she could as a
single mom but still felt all the stress
and and the struggle that a lot of
single moms face
and uh then alexis has got that in her
rearview mirror going i'm running i'm
running i'm running i'm gunning i'm not
doing this i'm not going to repeat we're
going to be in a different place uh what
a neat lady she's powerful powerful lady
very well done
very very well done
uh by the way george these people that
uh say the millennial generation is
useless and can't do anything uh we see
the most powerful millennials
anywhere on these stages i see you and
raise you one alexis right there there
you go
yeah so we've got um you know we've got
the
the young
uh 28 29 30 31 32 couples sometimes
sometimes singles
in here and they're the smartest and the
hardest working the most passionate and
so
uh you know you cannot lump an entire
generation under some stereotype it just
doesn't work there's deadbeats in the
boomers
and there's deadbeats in the millennials
and there's snowflakes in every one of
those generations people that think
they're special and just are good for
melting
and then there's the ones that get up
and get after it they're the ones that
do stuff like her that's the ones that
make it to the debt-free stage right
here and we celebrate those people well
and they make it to so much more i mean
that listen to what she's doing with her
life it's just amazing beautiful
beautiful transformation very very cool
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day matthew 6 1
beware of practicing your righteousness
before other people in order to be seen
by them
for then you will have no reward from
your father who is in heaven
mr rogers fred rogers said the media
shows the tines tiniest percentage of
what people do
there are millions and millions and
millions of people doing wonderful
things all over the world
and they're generally not the ones being
touted
in the news
that would be true
[Laughter]
pretty much guarantees you're not going
to be in the news
not exciting enough you gotta stir up
something you gotta stir up a ruckus to
get in the news dominic is with us
dominic is in denver hi dominic how are
you
hi dave how are you doing today better
than we deserve what's up
uh dave my question um for you today is
um
i'm trying my darndest to become a
babysitter millionaire
and um just wondering if uh i've been
was saving 15 of my income towards
retirement um i had stopped that for a
while but um been actively doing that
for
about two years now and um the way i've
set up my budget i've been able to
actually increase that to 21 and i'm
wanting their nose that's gonna
that's gonna do the job
how old are you
40. okay
what do you make
uh
currently making 72 a year net
um that will be going up though and
planning hopefully to retire by the age
of 55.
okay
so you're saving about 15 000 a year
um but you crank that up do you have a
home
i'm on baby step seven sir
oh good awesome yeah i would max out all
your retirement then
good credit what's the house worth
um
about between six and six twenty five
okay
well if you save um
excellent if you save 20 um
thousand bucks 30 000 bucks a year
um
in 10 years that's 300 000 that'll be
over a million alone
so i mean have you have you run the
calculations out on this invested in
mutual funds what it's going to turn
into
um yes i work well yes um i have uh
paired with one of your smart investor
pros um i have started a roth through
them
which i can only contribute uh 6 000 to
towards uh
per year
i also have an individual account that i
have set up with them as well
and
through my employer because
i work for a municipality
as a first responder i can
save up to i believe 20
grand through
my roth ira through the city yeah you're
rushed forward
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so
um i'm not maxing out through the city
um
retirement but i am that's the only
where that's the only way i can increase
more or less my
my
contribution well if you put 20 in a
401k roth and you put eight or six in a
401 in a roth ira
and then you have some side accounts
with your smartvestor pro that you're
investing you're investing 30 000 bucks
a year
you're gonna have substantial money if
you have you projected you know what
that's going to turn into 2500 bucks a
month how quick that turns into a
million dollars it's pretty dadgum quick
okay
i'm sorry i just i'm a little i guess um
ever since you know my dad died
a while back and i was
more or less um
put in a very comfortable place and um i
think that's when i got more
uh gazelle intense and um you know i
have uh really tried to
bear down the hatch and bust my butt to
make sure that some generational wealth
is left there for my daughter um you
know
when the good lord decides to take me so
amen i'm sorry for your loss what
happened to him
uh cancer sir how long ago
2014.
so you serve in the military six
uh no sir of
21 years right now as of now in the fire
service okay all right good for you well
done okay well you're uh
you're on track i think if you sit with
your smartvestor pro and you run some
projections out
i mean if the market averages 10 12
which it has somewhere in there you're
gonna um you know at 2 500 bucks a month
you you know on top of a 600 000 paid
for house on top of
what you've already put in
um you're gonna you know in those
tools that we were talking about you're
going to get there yeah and then the
baby steps millionaire's book i mean
he's right on track he fits the demo
perfectly yeah at his age to be hitting
millionaire status and it's a great
milestone i also want to remind him to
enjoy his life and live it and go on a
vacation and have fun and
you know take your daughter and do all
that kind of stuff too yeah in the midst
of it i mean we're not just saving money
we're not just savings machines we're
just being intentional and planning and
thinking it through but that's going to
be it's going to be a lot of money
you're going to have a lot of money you
don't need to worry about it ryan is
with us ryan is in north dakota fargo to
be precise hey ryan what's up
hey guys thanks for having me here um
you know we've been on the plan for
years we've listened for a long time and
i know most of your positions but uh
this one i'm truly curious about so
we're talking about moving up in-house
during steps four five and six
so we're two to three years away from
paying off the home you know we can see
seven down the road a little bit but it
is a starter home
and we have five people and two large
dogs and we're kind of stomping on each
other a little bit so
it's not so much the upgrades it's the
space and i guess the question is you
know is it worth pushing step seven
further down the road when we're so
close to it and getting into the home
that we want
you know versus
just kind of staying where we're at
maybe five to six years down the road we
could pay cash for something we like
so just curious your thoughts there so
you could if you moved you could pay it
off in five to six years instead of
three years
um no we'd be looking you know at
probably doubling what we want to do
you said you could pay off your current
home in three years
and you said if you buy yourself
and you said if you paid cash for the
upgrade you could do that in five to six
years if you could pay cash for you
could pay it off
it's the same numbers
uh sure yep but i guess inevitably we
would be taking on mortgage for longer
no
no you still misunderstood me let me try
one more time okay if you can sit there
for five or six years and pay cash for
the upgrade and during that time your
current residence will be paid off
correct
yep and during that time you would pay
cash and so in five to six years you
would be in the dream house
with cash
if you can do that with cash you can do
that and pay off the exact same amount
in a mortgage during that time
it's just going onto a mortgage instead
of into a savings account
sure sure okay so if it takes you two
years to pay off the house where you are
and it takes you six years to pay off
the house you move into that you love
then the difference we're discussing is
pushing it out four years
yep yep i follow okay now that sounds
reasonable so how much equity do you
have in your current house
[Music]
175
what's your household income
probably pretty close to that same
number actually and you're talking about
moving into what price
range 400 you know yeah 75 500 how old
are you
uh we're 40. so
um you know just here's where we're at
in the life cycle there yeah you got 8 9
year old 10 year old kids
yep yeah do it i would do it
yeah the the family really wants it and
i'm i'm so stuck i want step seven so
badly yeah
and it's it almost seems like i i may be
there in the family that wants that
badly that badly but everybody wants the
they want the same thing they ultimately
want a paid for house and they
ultimately want the wealth um they're
just it's just a question of how we're
how intense we're going to be to get
there that's the only how hard we're
going to how we're going to turn up the
burner here
so
let's just say out loud ryan
that if you stay and you pay off the
house and you save up for the move up or
if you make the move now and you pay it
off in five years or six years
in either case you're still weird
i mean you're not normal i mean
everybody else is going hello i'm gonna
be in debt the rest of my life
you know yeah we could pay off a 30-year
and 27 if we really try hard that's not
you man you're gonna be all right you're
still you're still in the weird bucket
dude you're fine
you're fine i would do that if i were in
your shoes no i wouldn't because i don't
borrow money but uh but
within the guidelines of what we teach
here you're fine george good show james
andrew zach ben and austin good show i'm
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you